what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i am going to be reacting to a video
that was on the roommates podcast
alpha male strategies debates whether or
not men should get married
um i thought this would be interesting
because
you know i've always wanted to get
married my parents have been married
forever and they've been super
successful
so i don't know just interesting to
watch before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
all right i think with the way the laws
are set up today it's just not favorable
for men
i would be a fool to get married and
then guys say well you got a prenup
well now i got to sit up and try to
convince the judge
that she didn't sign under distress and
it's it's just not
worth it to me oprah is never getting
married
these women understand that uh i can't
it's some other ones too i didn't get
that
thing off top of my head but it's been
some other real rich women that they are
smart enough
they're not ever getting married and so
yeah
i would agree with that point um i don't
agree that you know you shouldn't get
married but i do see what he's saying i
do think that the laws are
in favor of women and not men with the
way laws are
now i just think it has nothing to do
with being with one woman and then like
this
i understand most of my audience and i
point this out is a purple pill guys and
that's guys who
don't understand female nature but
they're willing to get into a
relationship
anyway and they ask me about marriage
and i just say with me
it's just not worth the chance and and
the thing is as you guys are on your
purpose
you don't know what this thing gonna be
so you might say okay
we can get married she's a school
teacher and so our incomes are equal but
you're on your purpose
who's to say what this podcast is worth
to spotify
or title or whoever you know 10 years
from now
and you didn't foresee that yeah you
know and that's the issue what guys got
to understand is that if you're on your
purpose
and you plan on starting your business
who knows what alpha male strategies is
10 years from now
okay i will say that i this might be an
unpopular opinion but i do think that
women
should be protected when it comes to
marriage and this is what i mean by that
if a woman chooses to stay home with the
kids for 20 years okay while you go to
work
and it doesn't work out after i do think
that the woman is then entitled to
compensation because
what is she worth in the workforce she
gave up her career
to help support yours now i don't you
know what how
how much is that worth what the numbers
would be i don't know but i do think
that
women should should deserve some sort of
legal protection
i might be a bill billionaire or
somebody might say hey we want you to do
showtime at apollo which leads to movies
you never know so guys think like well
i'm not i don't do nothing i'm gonna
i make 30 grand a year what's the big
deal yeah if you're on your purpose you
never know what five or ten years from
now gonna be
joe bezos didn't know he was to become
the richest man in the world you just
don't know
and so in my issue i would say jeff
bezos's wife is entitled to compensation
um i mean you guys can correct me if i'm
wrong but i believe
like she was very helpful she had kids
with him
you know if someone's giving up their
dreams for yours i do believe that
they're entitled to some form of
compensation if it doesn't work out
um the laws are probably too extreme
i'll probably give you that
man it's not good i understand it from
the female side
i told i tell guys this all the time i
understand
from the female side and i simply mean
this if you're a
21 year old woman and you go and get
with a
21 year old man and you give him 20
years of your best
of your life right and now you're 41
right
and now you're on the downside but now
he's just reading his peak
because he's reached his financial you
know top
and now he decides you know what that
that 20 year old waitress
at the job or by the job is you know
she's been giving me some choosing
signals
and then i'm looking at her and she's
got three kids she got three of my kids
and
her body ain't what it was 20 years ago
yeah is it that
so i get that aspect from the woman that
it gives her some assurances yeah yeah i
agree with that yeah
if i give you the best years of my life
that you can't just upgrade me
like a 20 years from now yeah
so i get it from their aspect but i'm
just looking at it from
my aspect that it don't work for me
either because
at that point now i got to pay you to
the day i
die for some i'm not even in that and
then you got a new dude
i'll do the child support yeah no
problem you don't even got to go take me
i put my cell phone child
right i'll put myself i'm gonna be a man
i'm gonna take care of my kids you gotta
fight me on no child support
it's the point of alimony losing my
house losing everything i work
is illegal it's a legal system yeah it
does go too far i don't think i know
enough about the laws to give
um a really well-educated opinion on
that but i see what he's saying i don't
think
that women are entitled to compensation
the rest of their life
but again it's hard because if a woman
gives up the early years of her career
to raise the kids
and you know then she's put in a
position where she has to start
from the bottom up when she might not
she may not necessarily have had to
start from the bottom up if she'd been
working the whole time
i think that's why some women they don't
want to leave their jobs to raise kids
they don't want to be stay-at-home moms
because they don't want to be put in a
position where their husband
you know has all the power i think that
kind of is that
is your main hurdle for the marriage yes
that's it that's the thing i kind of
want to give a case
for for marriage i want to
your females keep your females
brother so first i'm nigerian american
both my parents are nigerians so i come
from a completely different culture
when it comes to this oh yes yeah so the
way
so my argument with a lot of red pill
guys is too much of their understanding
of
women and marriage and relationship is
american they understand under the
concept of americans
i personally don't really date american
women as much so that's why i'm a little
bit different
so i want to begin with that but you
talked about
this they're changing too though huh i i
dated a couple in new york oh definitely
he's getting worse than us
definitely so me you gotta be careful
with the the first generation
okay so me i a lot like my girlfriend
right now she's from germany she's
germany
and nigerian so she's not even american
okay so
so to me one of the things i noticed
that you talked about
was building a legacy i don't know if
german women are any better i'm sorry i
lived in germany
i saw the girls there there's just as
much thought behavior
if not more to be honest because i
remember
when i was 18 i lived in germany for
three months and i told people that
like i was a virgin at that point and
people looked at me with like big eyes
like they could not believe that i was a
virgin
for having that generational wealth
right to be able to whatever your family
last name is
for uh 200 years and from now you know
it's going to be
that name it's going to be the
rockefellers the vanderbilt you know the
benzo stuff
you know the zuckerberg and then your
family last name so
end of the day every man hopefully wants
to reproduce
reproduce their offspring that's the
biggest thing and to me
i believe from what my dad taught me
the greatest thing you could give your
child obviously the financial thing is
blessing but it's a mindset mindset you
gotta take ams
is mine and whatever your descendants
you want them to have that same mindset
financially physically emotionally
spiritually
all that stuff so the number one thing
is that
you want your child to be in your home
right end of the day like that's that's
my philosophy i don't want you know what
i mean
baby mama some dude coming over teaching
all types of stuff being on her
whatever that and my child being a part
of that i want
my child my descendants to whoever's
gonna
when i die have all my resources i want
to be raising educated instruction
guiding that child in my path
so to me you want a woman who's gonna be
submissive feminine and respectful for
you throughout that period of time
so that you can be able to helpfully
raise a child
not even you gotta marry forever but at
least to be able to raise laid out a
foundation for the child so
to me though the i agree with you the
legalities of marriage is
horrible but in regards to a trustworthy
faithful respectful woman
to be able to one be someone you want to
reproduce with that's an important thing
and also you want someone to be able to
help
allow you to raise that child in your
home so that's why i personally push a
lot of my guys
to not just waste your time chasing a
billion different women but really to
find
a good respectful feminist submissive um
woman
to be able to build your family have
that family legacy to talk about
yeah i think what he's saying is facts
that's true
i think it's definitely good for kids to
be raised with both parents like i
truly appreciate the fact that both of
my parents were in the house
and i agree with that the issue i would
have is that
a lot of women know they get that
leverage with the situation with the
child and sometimes it causes them to
not
so this is what i've seen with other
guys that's been married is
that the woman knows that now i've got
him in a position to where
legally i can rape him if he leaves
and this naturally causes a person that
when they have that kind of leverage
to now they act different and what so
what a lot of guys is
either to keep that i become the beta
male
and just take her mouth or her lip it's
hard to be that dumb
but it's not impossible if you're
willing to walk away
if you're willing to if she's getting
too out of pocket and
thinking that she has that leverage and
power which is what i've seen a lot of
women that either guys learn how to just
deal with her
complaining stuff all the time or they
choose to walk away
the issue i have with it is that it
could not it might not be as happy as it
could be if she has that type of
leverage you know when you give a person
anybody leverage they use
i think i didn't mean to start it over
there it is
that the woman knows that now i've got
him in a position to where
legally i can rape him if he leaves
to now they act different and what so
what a lot of guys is
either to keep that i become the beta
male
and just take her mouth or her lip it's
hard to be that dumb
but it's not impossible if you're
willing to walk away
if you're willing to if she's getting
too out of pocket and
and thinking that she has that leverage
and power which is what i've seen a lot
of women that
either guys learn how to just deal with
her complain and stuff all the time or
they choose to walk away
the issue i have with it is that it
could not it might not be as happy as it
could be
if she has that type of leverage you
know when you give a person anybody
leverage they usually going to use it
in a but remember remember this is what
you have to clarify the people that you
deal with
tend to use it this is what i say
people reap what they sow he deals with
women
that use leverage when they have it now
you know i'm not pretending people don't
use leverage they 100
do but i
i feel like i know you guys hate it when
i say i feel like people should take
accountability for the people that they
allow into their lives
if you keep allowing people that act a
certain way that's on you
um it means you was negotiating on
something and you had the leverage and
you know i needed it yeah
i'm not gonna get much pull from you
because
you have the leverage and that's that's
the only issue with that but as far as
the child and you raise
my my thing when we talk about the
mindset is yes i would start my child
right off with entrepreneurship
early yeah early like entrepreneurship
be
have your own little candy store or
something we get the whole permit i
heard dame dash on the show time i said
my son has cookies and all this other
stuff
like so you want to instill that mindset
in him early yeah i think
that's great that's a great idea but i
don't feel like you have
to be in the house to instill that in
him
i think just all as long as you in his
life not statistically
not statistically okay that's fair and
so i want to
also talk about something that a lot of
people talk about when they say you know
a lot of times a man gets money a woman
divorces him takes all his money
so it's really fascinating going back to
book millionaire next door
actually the more money a man makes less
likely a woman is to divorce him
actually millionaires have the lowest
divorce rate to cross band across all
cultures
because going back to what you said this
is my personal opinion it's where i kind
of got this from you
that when you're a masculine man on your
purpose
always grinding you are the prize right
and when you find because the
key is that you got to find the right
woman obviously majority of women
don't have this mindset the same way
most men don't have the masculine
mindset but you gotta that's why i
usually think in general hard-working
people are hard to find
go across culturally when you find a
woman with the mindset
she knows that she's winning by being
with you right she knows that she like
like i said in my family the talking
back don't exist
yeah that's interesting
it's interesting because like oh shoot
guys
it's interesting because i could really
see both sides in that situation
i could see why men don't want to get
married today like that totally makes
sense
um but at the same time i don't know i'm
just more traditional i really
appreciated that my parents were married
i think they both benefited a lot from
being married
and genuinely they're probably more
successful than any of these people
giving advice
so that's just my two cents but let me
know in the comments if you guys agree
or you disagree don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos i will talk
to you guys next time